this where an actress who would it be
and that's not good yeah there's no such
thing as an ugly person we like the
color I like a spotty and for like I
think some spying like that's actually
pretty good
I have to fun like a nice soft banana he
threw it down and discussed declaring
that it was an Occupy do it bringing
through certain parts of that really
yeah on the inside I don't like that
smooth is [ __ ] this I'll tell you what
this is not organic no this is or no
it's not organic let's do it this is
attached yeah look at fat and short this
one is for sure organic this one not
organic this one this one's clearly the
organic banana organic yeah this one's
organic come on look at you
I just I'm only picking crushing it
I'm already got great I've already got
that great now this is kind of ruin my
Monday it's gonna be so good then let's
do it the best blackberries I've ever
had tastes like a cheap wine we have
uniform blackness smaller these are not
as good right
I found this bug in this this ones are
again now here's the problem these are
much greater promise you they're not
organic oh I think this is the organic
one because its taste is much stronger I
think I think this organic this is not
and the blue ones
all right show me about this work
first impressions visually these are
bigger smaller must be highly not
organic right probably organic but do
they think we're going to write that
they think that we think that this one
is organic so that means they're
actually this one's organic IFO
something's supposed to but they're not
my fruit of choice I know is assume
organic apples were smaller seers ears
this looks gross I feel like it's an out
in the Sun does it it looks bad it's
been cut poorly I'll probably take one
bite and put it back like at the
refrigerator in the morning time right
before you brush your teeth or pee the
textures off is like more powdery I can
see myself eating this at the library
because I'm bored that does organic
inorganic the moral of the story is that
the organic foods taste the work yeah
man